i'm going to spill some serious tea hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in my closet
[Music]
today's video was sponsored by bill barr
and i thought we would kill do a
hypothetical non-real bird with one
stone and tell you a story while also
going through some of my clothes since i
know i get a lot of questions about what
i wear and where i shop but first let me
tell you about my sponsor billbar so you
guys have heard me talk a lot about bell
bars there are so many super yummy
flavors and ingredients and i thought
we'd go back to like my all-time
favorite cookie dough chunk this one is
really the one that got me so into it
like it totally made me a believer
because they don't taste like chalky
protein bars they taste like a chocolate
bar so we're gonna dig into one of these
bad boys 15 grams of protein hello
i got a really chunky one too
now you get the full mom dance
[Music]
worth it for the build bar i wasn't
expecting to i wasn't expecting to let
loose this on oatmeal or like with some
toast in the morning you will love your
life you will become
a morning person like me i promise you
this so if you want to try these out
yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
you can pause the screen or look at the
description for my disclaimer including
a trigger warning as we will be
discussing disordered eating briefly but
if you're new here
subscribe
this is like not my usual setup i'm
doing something new today but ring that
bell so you never miss out on an episode
and also follow me over on tick tock and
instagram for more so i'm dying to get
dressed right now i want to get into
this heavily requested
top secret never before shared story
right here right now but first your girl
needs to get dressed this is my uniform
i know but
sometimes you gotta switch up the
uniform do some kind of like a
transition
transition
[Music]
okay first fit as they say in gen zed
culture um this is a new dress i just
got from zimmerman i actually bought it
from the real real so i got it like
super discounted but i couldn't resist
because i love zimmerman uh as a
designer but i just very rarely feel
like i can justify buying something for
full price um so yeah i got a good deal
on this and i just thought it was so
beautiful the colors were so nice i love
a high neck i might take it in just a
little bit because i feel like it could
be taken in a bit a little bit
thankfully my mother is like martha
stewart and she's a seamstress and can
do all the things so that comes in handy
so that's probably my plan but yeah you
can tie it up here apparently you could
tie in the back
you could tie it in the front i don't
really know what's best i don't know
that i like that i kind of like the side
but yeah i like the tie at the top
it's super cute good for transitioning i
feel from like spring to summer to fall
because of the colors
and yeah it's comfortable it's light
it's movable it's danceable
i'm feeling it okay so story time if you
guys recall
a while ago i posted a review of
harper's bazaar's
interview like the wedding day interview
with kelly ripa back in
like november 2020. those were tough
times and i record all my videos well in
advance because i'm like
hashtag type a and then like a week
before my editor will then take all the
footage and usually like stitch it
together with the original interview the
clips from the original video from
youtube well i remember when i watched
the harper's bazaar interview
um for the first time with kelly ripa i
saw
for sure
like all the red flags wagon wagon
waving i don't know but they were they
were on the move and the day i went to
actually record the video i searched
harper's bazaar kelly ripa so i could
like watch it while i was commenting on
it and the video was gone
not available and i was like
[ __ ]
and that was the first time
actually that that had happened to me
but since then it has happened a few
times and so now i will just like pull
them well before i even record just as a
safeguard and that way we don't have
that issue down the road but anyways i
was able to find the video because we
still had the link that we were
originally using the original link and
the link worked it just was not
searchable so it seems like it wasn't
fully scraped but it was just maybe
moved to like an unlisted link maybe by
accident maybe not it was strange but i
was just happy that the video didn't
completely disappear off the face of the
earth and i could continue on making my
video okay hold that thought i'm gonna
change if i want to do one of these
for like transition for coming in
wow that feels
dizzying okay so i just actually looked
at this top because i didn't even know
who made it but the the tag says
sunday's best i'm pretty sure i got it
from auritzia because i got two i got a
blue one too
um but it's a really good staple the
only thing i don't like about it is that
it's like really short like it it only
goes to like here and i got a long torso
so it's perfect with like a nice high
waisted skirt like this this is from
seventh
what's it called seven for all mankind
seven for all mankind what does that
mean can someone tell me seven for all
mankind anyways i got this on sale for
like 40 off or something so i was like
love it and i love the pink it's got
like a little fringe at the bottom
i don't know if you can see
um so like maybe it's supposed to be
paired with black but i don't i don't
like pink and black together it just
feels a little like skater girl avril
lavigne we're still rocking in circa
2002
kind of thing not my jam but if you want
to rock it you rock it you probably can
do it better than i can um
yeah so that's the fit
so back to my story where was i
okay so yeah i recorded the video it was
edited i posted it and i got a lot of
noise largely i think because the video
was just like so triggering
and obviously problematic if you guys
watched it you know what i'm talking
about and then a few weeks later
i get an email from kelly ripa's pr team
basically they
very respectfully told me
that
the video got taken down from the
harper's bazaar kind of inventory
because it was filmed before they
represented her
and for whatever reason they did not
properly contextualize
uh that she was apparently on some kind
of like a cleanse or like a detox on one
of the days that they were shooting that
she was describing which i thought of
course was a strange explanation given
that i think the most i don't know
shocking takeaway that i got from that
interview was that she said she ate the
exact same foods
every single day for
365 days if you were to ask me this one
year from now i will have three entirely
different meals
but it will be
the same rotation of meals for just
about a year she says this in the video
very very clearly and it's not really a
special kind of cleanse if you're eating
that way every single day for a full
year okay hold that thought i got
another fit
okay so this is a cute little jumper
from faithful the brand i got it on the
real reel so i also got it at a
discounted price which we love um but
faithful the brand is like one of my
favorite designers um when i have a
special occasion like a summer wedding
or like a special photo shoot and that's
usually one of the brands that i will
splurge on so i do have a few nice
pieces by them um but i really love this
because i thought the color was just
right on me i like blues on me and the
fabric is so light and airy which is
very typical with their products um and
i got it for a good trace and i just
thought it was like really cute for
anything like summer parties something
that could be like a little dressy but
also um still really fun for the summer
i'm going to pei i'm going to exuma for
a bachelorette um i've got a summer
wedding to go to which may have other
kinds of getting ready ensembles going
on and who knows like maybe i'll take a
little weekend trip with my hubby to to
the states at some point which would be
a nice little thing to tote along
because it's so airy and fun for the
summer okay so back to the story
basically they very respectfully asked
me to take the video down because they
said that my critique was causing other
people to criticize her as well and you
know it's really never ever my goal to
criticize anyone personally especially
someone like kelly i honestly spent i
don't know most of my teen years and my
young adulthood years obsessed with
watching kelly i think she's smart i
think she's talented i think she's
obviously beautiful and most importantly
i think she's like really really really
hilarious the woman is magic on camera
so it's so obvious to me why she's done
so well on tv like i could watch that
woman
all day but the diet recall video
was different like
even though i love kelly it was
triggering as f for me to watch it and i
strongly believe that all public figures
need to be held accountable for the
content that they put out there
obviously anyone who works in the public
eye myself included has been mistakenly
misquoted or misrepresented
and that's like really unfortunate but
it does happen all the time but i really
think that there's like a huge
difference between a sound bite getting
kind of taken out of context and like an
entire interview being completely
misrepresented so yeah they asked her
questions she answered them and the
answers that she gave may have been
honest which i honestly have a lot of
empathy for as someone who used to have
very similar food experiences but this
information can be dangerous in the
hands of young impressionable viewers
who would eventually try to do the same
like kelly is beautiful she's thin so of
course girls are going to want to eat
with the same rigidity as she does to
look the way she does and coincidentally
you know the years i was struggling the
most with my eating disorder were really
the years that i spent watching kelly's
show and while my ed has nothing
specifically to do with her hearing her
testimony of her diet like really just
drove me right back to that sad place in
my life and made me realize how easy it
would be for me to go back it's like
hearing about these celebrities diet
secrets can be such a slippery slope and
you seriously don't see how that's a
slippery slope so i have to call this
out like i have to undo the damage that
some of these interviews do i have to
pick it apart and explain to the world
that no you do not need to eat the same
thing every day to be healthy or fit you
don't have to limit yourself to a single
dark chocolate almond for dessert and
you don't need to have greens powder to
alkalinize your digestive system every
day okay put a pain in that i got one
more fit for you
all right
this is my last
look for today and i'm probably going to
wear this out tonight because easy and
cash um these are my favorite mom jeans
appropriately they're by mother that's
the brand name and i got like a little
bit of rippage but like not so obnoxious
that you get your foot stuck in every
single time you put them on like most of
my jeans that are like this um i like a
nice ultra high waist the top and the
belt are from bash
another one of my all-time favorite
designers i have a lot of their stuff um
they just fit me they're kind of
feminine but not like girly that's
really my look and um i loved this
blouse so much this is gonna be perfect
for
like maybe like mother's day brunch or
something like that that's kind of what
i'm feeling okay so back to the story so
at that point like i i could have just
let it go because you know it's off the
internet poof hurrah
but i really think that
just as fast as one piece of problematic
content will like disappear
another will appear and no amount of
positive nutrition content
is going to be able to compete with
skinny inspo that's just not where our
society is at right now so i have to use
my voice and try to break it down i have
to make an effort to contribute to
the other side anyways um kelly's team
basically is not the first to ask me to
take my videos down and they're not
likely going to be the last but i stand
by my message and i'm so so so
appreciative of all of you guys who
stand by it too
so yeah this was like a fun little
format that i wanted to try out for you
guys um for like story time and i have
lots more clothes and makeup too but
like let's be real i'm no makeup artist
but if you guys want more story times
and more clothing try ons let me know in
the comment section below but that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with who or what you'd like to see me do
a story time on next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]